all right listen up  sheriff's department's close by we'll be  safe there okay stay close  i'll get you out of here  all right keep it together yeah okay we  gotta make it to that sheriff's station  oh my god  [Music]  we gotta get thrown stay together keep  moving  and don't get bit go  hey are you getting this yeah what is  up all right let's go  [Music]  [Music]  ain't that some these are some racist  [ __ ] zombies why would you even  lock the door i mean the window's broken  and  oh oh hell no  no no no  oh um oh what is that they seriously  wouldn't let her eat us  hey guys isn't this great  these racist zombies are leaving us  alone come on we're having a party  [Music]  the beer is here  [Applause]  [Music]  you